[Music]
this is a segment where viewers try to
find mistakes on our show and we're the
only show that challenges viewers to
find mistakes because we're that
confident right that we don't make them
cocky even cocky yeah yeah so far
hundreds and hundreds of people have
challenged us not one winner no no one
has found us making an area bring it up
we bat him down exactly yeah
that's the relationship we have with our
viewer huh well tonight a fan named Todd
Andrew says he thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened during a
recent comedy bit about audience members
who were too hot to laugh Conan Conan
Conan I have been waiting for this
moment for so long I've been watching
your show forever you guys are smart
you're funny but you're not smart enough
to pick up on one thing you had a bit
here on Wednesday the 17th about the
audience member who's too hot to laugh
today they decided to bring their dog
now that just blows me away who brings a
dog to a TV show except dogs don't sweat
everybody knows that dogs don't sweat
isn't that right Mina yeah she thinks so
too anyways I like to say are you gonna
get out of this one looks like I just
made chump me out of the maestro but
bile
I hate that guy he looks like the devil
after he got high if he gets fired he
got high got fire yeah still the devil
dude no no I don't hate that guy he's
doing his best right that's just in a
mistake we invited him to do that
exactly not to grow that facial hair but
to do that well Todd I respect I respect
your integrity I respect that you're a
fan of the show but I'm sorry you are
dead wrong dogs do sweat in fact I have
actual clinical research that you can't
make up to back me up on this one
Conan's right Todd dog sweat just like
people do when they're hot or nervous or
scared allow me to demonstrate
first heat second nervousness ooh Lala
boy
and third fear looks like I just made
Chum meat out of the maestro well the
challenge still stands if you think
you've sported an era la ah shell
reported at team koco.com slash haha I
found an error we will sort it out right
here on the air let's see if you have
what it takes to make chunk meat out of
the maestro
you